hey youtubers is Charlie this is gonna
be my agents of shield episode 10 video
the mid-season finale just careful for
spoilers if you haven't seen it yet I've
got a brilliant idea let's go to an
alien planet and summon a hell Beast
what could possibly go wrong think of
this is like the Tatooine episode and
Clark Gregg actually said that that line
that Coulson spoke goddamn Tatooine was
actually written into the script he
joked that it was repayment for them
taking out these aren't the droids
you're looking for a lie that he was
supposed to get last year I guess there
was a bunch of Star Wars they cut out of
the script
he's like shields big comic book II the
guy that collects trading cards all
kinds of nostalgia but once we get
through top five WTF we need to address
Captain America Civil War stuff because
this is gonna overlap the second half of
the seasons gonna overlap with Captain
America Civil War in agent Carter season
two so here we go top five WTF Fitz
keeps trying to kill Ward on the alien
planet while looking for will well
they're looking though they see this
agent Hydra statue and find out that the
creature it they just keep calling it it
used to live there it's also seized and
takes pictures of in ancient city the
story that the creature tells is this
ancient tale about a civilization that
could have done amazing things there are
relatively advanced but they turn on
each other and destroyed the planet now
before the speech most people thought
that the creature itself was responsible
for the desolation on the planet
depending on who you believe the things
that are playing out on earth now played
out on that alien planet and it led to
its downfall like the proliferation of
Inhumans maybe so maybe the creature
coming back and trying to do the same
thing on earth is also going to lead to
a similar outcome or maybe the creature
is going to try and help the way they
played it it was relatively ambiguous
like you're meant to think that this
alien creature is a villain but some of
the things he says makes it sound like
he has good intentions on a my number
four WTF Simmons let's lash out and he
ends up killing all the stored in humans
that they're keeping for that mystery
creature to lead as an army so armies
taken care of you know check that box
off but not to worry about them but the
last character is a really nice mirror
for what's going on with the mystery
creature from the alien planet like we
know Andrews a good character but he's
done really terrible things so it seems
like Mae wants to put him down like she
sees the devastation that he's wrought
like all the people that he's killed and
it seems like the takeaway is that
Andrew
is too far gone so I think we're meant
to ask the same questions of this new
mystery in human creature that's
inhabiting Ward's body now like does it
have good intentions is it too far gone
for the difference I think is that there
is some Andrew left inside that lash
character I think he is trying to help
so there might be some redemption for
him Ward though seems like he's being
positioned as the real big bad of the
season so I think ultimately there will
be no redemption for that character
whatever good intentions the mystery
Hydra creature has we're gonna have to
talk about what we're gonna call this
mystery creature I think we're gonna
have to wait till next season to give it
a name but like it probably isn't even a
bad name because it's so old
anima number 3w CFO slightly more
positive secret warriors rolls out with
me so we finally get to see Daisy's
secret warriors kicking some ass we get
to see Joey use his powers to stop
bullets the cool thing about this though
is that I don't think that Joey knew
that he was gonna be able to stop those
bullets I think he was throwing himself
into their path just so she wouldn't get
shot and him melting the bullets was
more of an instinctual thing you know
more of a reaction
Joey was so much fun in this episode two
telekinesis is that the one where they
mess with the minds or is that the one
where you move stuff around with your
minds we're all scared here
well maybe not me everybody but Mei is
really scared to be here I know my
number two WTF Fitz's takedown with the
flare gun coolest looking takedown in
the episode when he took down the
inhuman creature that was possessing
well and then Coulson killing Ward by
crushing his chest most satisfying kill
in the episode and if you wonder why
Coulson didn't like shoot him in the
head I think they wanted the kill to
feel much more personal flare gun was
like the spectacular kill Coulson wanted
Ward to look into his eyes as he was
killing him very dark very good very
awesome Coulson moment in that look that
he gives Fitz at the end of the episode
that that knowing look like yes I did a
terrible thing I'm gonna have to live
with it I think the reason that Coulson
dropped his hand like he took his hand
off and dropped it on the ground next to
Ward's body is just because he didn't
want to be reminded of what he did
trying to leave all his emotional
baggage behind but Ward brings that back
with him when surprise surprise never
Owen WTF the creature comes back
possessing Ward's body so it's like
Coulson tries to bury all his bad
feelings like I'm gonna lay this to rest
but it comes back to life literally in
back into the world
so Coulson's gonna have to deal with it
whether he likes to or not
so the fun of the word character now is
that all of the shield characters think
that it's over and done but we can
finally forget about Ward nope wrong
can't forget about him because he's
gonna be in your face controlling an
army of Inhumans presumably so I will
say hands down this is my favorite
direction for the ward character because
he was already evil like he's going from
evil to a different kind of evil
I think the twist in season 1 when he
went from super duper Boy Scout to like
crazy evil Ward was way too dramatic
like they tried to make him seem too
bland before they made him evil is much
more fun when an evil character like
Loki for instance tries to be good a
little bit but then they realized their
true nature is to be evil so they're
like fine I'm just gonna be super evil
that feels a little more authentic to
the word character like they just kept
making him more and more psycho like the
terrible things that he did to his
family so you guys let me know in the
comments what did you think about this
Ward twist and what do you think is
going on with this mystery inhuman
creature that came through the portal I
don't want to just assume that he's
going to seek out an army to try and
take over the earth it seems like based
on the hopeful tone when he talked about
that foreign civilization on the alien
planet like they could have been
beautiful they could have been great I
think he's gonna try and help that
happen on earth but the thing is is
there's already a bunch of people on
earth that have their own ideas about
the direction they want things to go you
have the Avengers you have all these new
inhuman people on agents of shield what
are they gonna say about this creatures
plan is going to start getting real
and didn't you love how they kind of
tease civil war on that foreign planet
like oh they started warring with each
other they were relatively advanced
almost as if what's happening with civil
war in the spring next year happened on
that other planet it's a little
tongue-in-cheek and I think that's just
to make this foreign creature sound a
little more ambiguous like he's just not
like a mustache twirling villain he
actually does want to make things better
I know we had that Tatooine Star Wars
reference you know that was a lot of fun
but that's also kind of the same thing
that's going on in the Star Wars movies
with the first-order it's like yeah
they're evil but they have this plan for
the galaxy they want to make it better
it's just that their plan conflicts with
the other characters plans so what about
civil war you asked like how is this
going to crossover because the last
couple of episodes of agents of shield
will be airing when Captain America
Civil War hits theaters so my guess is
that with the fever pitch with which
things are proceeding though does
the open war in humans in the streets
like it'll be a full-blown battle royale
this Hydra creature will have a bunch of
acolytes a bunch of followers who buy
into its plan then Coulson will have his
secret warriors and they'll just be
going at it with all this grandeur you
know Marvel Cinematic Universe warring
going on to the background Captain
America vs Iron Man etc I know the big
question is is will Avengers come on
agents of shield will agents of shield
characters going to the movies I
definitely do not expect any of the TV
characters to be in Captain America
Civil War but I do think that they will
be referencing each other and I do think
we'll see at least one minor character
from the movies appear on agents of
shield in a slightly bigger way than we
did last year with the Avengers age of
Ultron crossover that was like a
glorified Skype call I was so
disappointed in that but in case you
missed it Mockingbird actually
referenced Nick Fury in this episode she
said that Nick Fury in the wake of
Winter Soldier sent them to find the
monolith and keep it out of hydras hands
so maybe Nick Fury knows about this
crazy Hydra plan to bring this creature
back so if anything I feel like there's
a good possibility of like a Nick Fury
crossover but I'm actually up the funny
thing is is I'm not expecting Nick Fury
to appear in Captain America Civil War
but what about agent Carter season two
so here's the deal with the schedule if
you guys didn't watch agent Carter
earlier this year it aired in January
whenever shield was on break shield
comes back in March
so agent Carter is gonna air it's eight
episodes when shield would normally be
airing episodes it's basically just like
replacing shield for eight weeks
starting in January they did move the
premiere date a little bit so I think
it's gonna be like the end of January
when agent Carter starts be sure to
subscribe to get those videos I'm gonna
do weekly videos just like I do for
shield if you did not watch season one
you might be able to find it on Netflix
pretty soon it's only eight episodes so
it's like a relatively low time
investment but all-in-all I feel like
this mid-season finale you know shields
mid-season finale was the most epic so
far you know just like big sweeping epic
story you know multiple planets big
Inhumans war going on in the background
flash for example was a much more
personal story it was mostly about
forgiveness much more self-contained
much more personal story Gotham was kind
of in-between we'll have to see what
arrow is like tonight I think arrows
gonna be a much more personal story -
don't forget arrow mid-season finale
tonight but in case you guys haven't
seen it you can click here for my
Captain America civil war trailer
you all kinds of that movies gonna be so
crazy and you can click here for my
flash midseason finale video from last
night if you haven't seen it yet thank
you so much for watching everybody let's
high five I'll see you guys tonight
you